zum beispiel wenn ich hier aus dem haus
gekommen sofort ganz viel ich auch alex
flossen brutalen körper von costa ich
leider nie so kurze zeit später kommt
ein anderer rein stellt sich nicht ganz
rechts anders und lässt es in der mitte
frei sondern stellt sich einfach genau
neben euch und ihr denkt euch so dicker
jedoch etwa nach ganz rechts
herzlich willkommen beim ein video ja
also ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut
ja ungefähr vor einem monat kam mein
letztes jungs mädchen thema war ein
bisschen schade
das video wurde irgendwie wegen dem song
blame habe 18 eingestuft obwohl das
hotel wirklich nicht so schlimm war er
deswegen weiß ich nicht wer von euch das
alles gesehen hat ich war links euch auf
jeden fall am ende noch mal ist er doch
eigentlich komplett egal wir machen
heute schön weiter mit einem neuen thema
wir haben ja gerade dezember unter der
woche kommt jeden tag um 15 von myvideo
da braucht man schon um 11 uhr
und ihr könnt doch viel gewinnen das ist
aber alles in meinen letzten video läuft
welche playstation weißt du das mal ich
finde schwarz coole
ja ich meine die so leute iphone ist
besteht also ich habe jetzt hier ein
space grau und noch die ps4 auf jeden
fall ein sehr lustiges gefühl einfach
mal einzukaufen und zu wissen dass es
nicht viel mehr will ich gar nicht sagen
wir legen sofort mal los und zwar habe
ich mich mal wieder hingesetzt und habe
überlegt über was kannst du heute reden
und wahrscheinlich habe das auch schon
am titel gelesen es geht heute um 10
geheimnisse von denen ich bis jetzt als
abgefunden habe also zwei fehlen noch
vielleicht fahren wir die im laufe des
videos sein ich weiß es nicht also zehn
geheimnisse die 95 prozent aller jungs
mädchen nicht erzählen
christa titel jetzt fragt euch
sicherlich ja alex wieso dann 95 94
prozent ganz einfach ich bin auf die
straße gegangen habe 1000 menschen
befragt und von diesen 1000 menschen
konnten wir 950 diese sache nicht nennen
deswegen 95 prozent nicht was es können
noch 90 sein aber ich finde 95 40
schülern dann würde ich jetzt aber sagen
wir fangen wirklich an ich bin mal
gespannt vielleicht schaffen wir heute
wieder die 10.000 likes also für die
nächsten paar klassen nach oben da und
schreibt gerne auch in die kommentare
was ich das nächste mal reden soll und
wir starten mit punkt nummer eins in der
mich auch wirklich sehr sehr lange
beschäftigt habe ich mein ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile ungefähr habe die schuhe an
habe bin ich 180 ich würde mal sagen das
liegt so offen durchschnitt aber ich bin
jetzt nicht so der extrem große mensch
auch wenn viele irgendwie manchmal sagen
ja in den videos kommen so viel größer
als im reallife also wenn ich welche von
euch auf der straße treffen sagen immer
ich doch du bist größer geschrieben als
er mit ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich
schon denken was ich meine
also vor allem somit 12 13 14 jahren
wenn viele der jungs schon extrem
wachsen manche aber noch nicht zum
beispiel ich war auch wirklich in der
neuen klasse war ich glaube ich gerade
mal 1 55 oder 61 keine ahnung wann will
als mann oder als junge eigentlich immer
besonders groß sein und es sehr sehr oft
mit seiner eigenen größe und zufrieden
vor allem wenn man halt extrem klein ist
dann gibt es ja zum beispiel auch viele
leute die sich darüber lustig machen
wenn sie einfach schon so groß
und man selber erst so groß und man
selber lacht halt immer mit aber im
endeffekt ja tut das schon weh zu wissen
dass ein kleiner pisser bahn hält es
halt irgendwie geheim und lässt es sich
nicht anmerken so kommen wir zunächst
eine sache die mir eigentlich auch
ziemlich schnell eingefallen ist jetzt
mal als beispiel instagram es gibt ja
wirklich so viele frauen und mädchen die
fotos von ihrer figur posten und da gibt
es noch viel viel mehr mädchen die sich
diese frauen also ich jetzt mal davon
aus mädchen nehmen sich frauen als
vorbild weil diese haltung extrem schöne
figur haben und wahrscheinlich denken
die meisten von euch die jungs ist das
eigentlich egal ob die jetzt so viel wie
oder vielleicht so viel wiegen die haben
bestimmt keine vorbilder oder so an
denen die sich körperlich orientieren
sie ist voll kranken aber das ist ganz
offensichtlich falsch es gibt auch sehr
viele jungs ich würde eigentlich sagen
fast alle die gegen wen haben wo die
sagen die hat aber einen krassen körper
so wie ich auch gern aus sind zum
beispiel wenn ich hier aus dem haus
gekommen sofort ganz will ich auch alex
und brutalen körper voll costa ich auch
so sehen dass wir da noch nie so ja das
war eigentlich der zweite punkt also wir
haben auch körperliche vorbilder so
kommen wir zum nächsten punkt das ist
das muss ich auch auf jeden fall
mitnehmen bei mir ist aktuell ich gehe
eigentlich kaum noch feiern vor allem
ich so zu dieser hip hop musik muss dann
wirklich darum geht wie heute werden
erklärt na ja ich sag mal so diese klubs
halt wo die meisten leute hingehen um
irgendwen kennenzulernen
kennt man ja und dann ist es ja meistens
so dass die jungs oder sehr viele jungs
die haben so das heftigste
selbstbewusstsein und gehen von dieser
frau zunächst frauen machen einfach jede
frau an und kriegen so einen korb nach
dem anderen und dann sagen sie ja js
juckt mich gar nicht aber im endeffekt
tut das richtig weh vor allem an musste
erst mal sogar seinen eigenen schatten
springen und wenn man dann einen korb
nach dem anderen bekommen also wenn euch
als mädchen jemand an macht und ihr denn
so richtig fetten korb gibt könnt ihr
davon ausgehen dass hat den richtig
getroffen kommen wir auch schon zur
nächsten sache und zwar gibt es ja sehr
viele verschiedene lebewesen auf diesem
planeten es gibt säugetiere es gibt
amphibien es gibt reptilien und es gibt
noch wohl wir sind auch säugetier wurde
ja und all diese lebewesen haben ja
irgendwelche instinkte zum beispiel eine
spinne muss überleben baut ihr netz
insekten fliegen rein spinne ist das auf
die jungs zum beispiel haben auch unsere
instinkte
das ist wirklich ein instinkt das macht
man ganz bewusst auch wenn man nur
freuen hat und die noch so gut aussieht
man guckt halt manchmal instinktiv
anderen weiblichen personen hinterher
das ist halt so als wenn jemand euren
körper fernsteuert so mit so einem
joystick die darum drehen obwohl man das
nicht will ist auf jeden fall schwer zu
erklären und das dann noch zuzugeben
vielleicht auch vor der eigenen freundin
dass es noch schwerer sagt dann einfach
ich habe ein geiles auto gesehen oder so
metapher geiles auto brauche ich habe
ein richtig geiles gerät gesehen
er bezieht sich einig auf essen für uns
jungs oder männer
es ist wirklich extrem schwer frauen die
wirkliche meinung die man hat zu ihrer
figur zu sagen okay das soll es auch
keinen fall oberflächlich klinge nicht
meinen jede frau man kann ja gar nicht
sagen ist ist jetzt eine frau wenn er zu
dick oder zu dünn ich meine sieht ja
jeder anlass für manche ist das schon zu
dick für manche sind schon zu dünn und
so weiter also das will ich jetzt gar
nicht damit meinen aber wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel von einer guten freundin
noch von der eigenen freundin gefragt
wird ja findest du meine figur gerade
cool oder nicht dass muss man halt
irgendwie meistens geheim halten weil
man ganz genau weiss man kann nicht
sagen ja das ist gerade echt ein
bisschen zu dünn oder meiner meinung
nach bis zu ein bisschen zu dick
egal was man sagt das wäre nicht gut ich
glaube die meisten trauen sich da auch
gar nicht wirklich das zu sagen was sie
denken weil man könne die personen damit
verletzen
man kann sie sauer machen was auch immer
ja das ist mir auch noch eingefallen
das ist auch noch richtig den nächsten
punkt habe ich irgendwo im internet
gefunden und zwar haben wir einen
vorteil wir können ihm stehen wissen und
als man tut man ja auch eigentlich mal
so als könne man überall und neben jedem
pissen wie machen will
das hat sich jetzt wohl richtig an nur
passt auch zum beispiel öffentliche
toiletten man geht auf die toilette da
sind 33 ps war's oder drei pisten
nebeneinander keine ahnung wie das heißt
alle drei sind frei und man geht anders
ganz linke kurze zeit später kommt ein
anderer rein stellt sich nicht ganz
rechts anders und lässt es in der mitte
frei sondern stellt sich einfach genau
neben euch und ihr denkt euch so dicker
jedoch etwa nach ganz rechts das ist
halt irgendwie für die meisten so ein
bisschen wenn man besoffen ist es ist
scheißegal aber er möchte dass im
zustand so wie man halt meistens ist
natürlich ist jetzt für manch extrem
unangenehm für manche eher weniger aber
so wie ich es analysiert habe für 95
prozent die wollen es halt nicht zugeben
dass es so ist aber es ist so also
können schon relativ glücklich sein als
mädchen dass hier nur so toiletten habe
die immerzu sind oder ist das doch
eigentlich vielleicht gibt es ja offen
aber diese meistens so etliche
öffentliche
jedoch auf und kommen jetzt auch schon
zum letzten punkt die nicht doch
analysiert habe und zwar wenn man jetzt
junge oder als meine freundin hat und
diese freundin aber auch noch sehr sehr
viel kontakt hat zu anderen männlichen
personen mit denen sie wirklich nur
befreundet ist oder so und euch dann zum
beispiel davon erzählt jung war letztens
mit dem unterwegs der so und so drauf
aber der ist voll cool der ist voll
witzig auch wenn sich das bild an hört
viele männer 5 90 prozent genau sehen
das dann irgendwie so als konkurrenz und
folger irgendwie besser sein obwohl da
ja gar nichts ist zwischen den person
wenn ihr bestehen ja diesem punkt konnte
ich auch herausfiltern wollte ich euch
gerne noch mitteilen und dann haben wir
auch schon acht stück das auch ganz gut
ich weiß ganz genau ich kann das ja
sogar sehen die meisten männer wollen
gar nicht zugeben dass die sonne video
wie ich es jetzt gerade gemacht habt
wirklich auch anschauen nur wenn ich mal
meinen analytics gucken kann ich ganz
genau sehen das vielleicht 65 prozent
weiblich sind 35 prozent aber auch
männlich und dann heißt es auch alex wie
jungs mädchen thema das gucke ich mir
doch nicht an ich vergessens videos mit
seinen auto oder wenn er süßigkeiten an
bringt ja heute so viel dass man dazu
last nach oben da 10.000 likes sind ja
vielleicht drin checkt auf jeden fall
die letzten videos ab auch vielleicht
selbst die jungs mädchen thema wenn es
noch nicht gesehen habt instagram
snatchers kurz eingeblendet und wir
sehen uns dann schon morgen wieder um 15
uhr gibt's neues video
haut rein